hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well section 5 of
William James essay the will to believe
is entitled empiricism and absolutism
and he views these as two different you
might say intellectual compartments on a
global scale that that individuals adopt
now there also you could say
ideal types it's very rare that you can
find somebody who's a pure absolutist
and as we're going to see empiricists
are not always behaving empirically as a
matter of fact they often behave like
absolutist in certain respects and we
could think of a continuum between them
he's also going to contrast them here
very briefly to scepticism so it's worth
talking about
this contrast at first he says for the
purposes of this discussion we are on
what he calls dogmatic ground dogmatic
ground means that there are some things
that you have to accept you have to
believe in order to make any sort of
progress he says ground which leaves
systematic philosophical skepticism
altogether out of account so he's
putting that aside and then he says well
what is that skepticism the postulate
that there is truth
and that it is the destiny of our minds
to attain it
we are deliberately resolving to make
but the skeptic will not make that so
the skeptic is not just saying well
there is no truth or what is truth the
skeptic is also to some degree or in
some way calling into question or even
actively denying our capacity as knowing
subjects to know what the truth is
and so you know there's a varieties of
skepticism out there and we don't have
to get into that because James says
we're primarily interested in this
contrast between two dogmatic ways of
approaching things that of the
empiricist and that of the absolutist so
then he goes on he says the faith that
truth exists and that our minds can find
it may be held in two different ways one
of these is the empiricist way the other
is the absolutist way and he says these
are ways of believing in truth of
thinking that there is truth out there
so what's the difference he says the
absolutist say that not only can we
attain to knowing truth but we can know
when we have attained to knowing it well
the empiricists think that although we
may attain it we cannot infallibly know
when and you might say isn't there a bit
of confusion here what do you mean to
say that you know the truth but you
don't know that you know the truth
wouldn't knowing the truth automatically
provide its own sort of certitude or its
own self evidence or something like that
and James would say aha you're an
absolutist an absolutist of one form or
another so the empiricist says that
truth exists so does the absolutist both
of them say that we can attain the truth
where is the vital difference the
empiricist says we can't be sure that we
actually have the truth
we can go by probabilities or our best
guesses up to this point whereas the
absolutist says no I can know for
certain that this is the truth and so
you know we might see this as a new
version of continental rationalism verse
British empiricism but you know William
James has pointed out in other places
that the empiricists as a school were
often not quite empirical enough and
that there's a lot of rationalism still
in there be that as it may
let's go on he says that to know is one
thing to know for certain that we know
is another we can hold the first being
possible without the second so the
empiricist is willing to say yes we can
know things we just can't always know
that we know them and that's not denying
that we can't ever know that we know
them just saying sometimes we have to be
unsure sometimes we say I think I know
this but I am not entirely sure if you
want to call that belief if you want to
call that faith if you want to call that
something other than knowledge as such
go on ahead that's perfectly fine so
then he says what these do is show very
different degrees of dogmatism in their
lives so it's not just about purely
intellectual or theoretical matters it's
also about practical matters as well and
then he says if we look at the history
of opinions we can see that the
empiricist tendency now notice the term
here has largely prevailed it doesn't
mean that it dominated it doesn't mean
that you can identify it with science so
the empiricist tendency is found in
science where in philosophy the
absolutist tendency has had everything
its own way and then he's got a nice
line here the characteristic sort of
happiness which philosophies yield has
mainly consisted in the conviction felt
by each successive school or system that
by it bottom certitude had been attained
other philosophies are collections of
opinions mostly false
my philosophy gives standing ground
forever who does not recognize than this
the key note of every system worthy of
its name so he's saying most
philosophers up until his time and you
can't necessarily say this about all
philosophers after James or his own mode
of philosophy pragmatism have been
absolutists interestingly even this is a
bit of a side note the schools that
stressed how they were we could say
empirical or excist an
sure pick whatever you want and that
they were getting away from absolutism
very often as they turned into schools
they became absolutists of their own
didn't they
so you can find new versions of
dogmatism arising at every point he uses
as an example scholastic orthodoxy what
does he mean by scholastic orthodoxy
he's talking about that of the Middle
Ages that we can identify not just with
Thomas Aquinas but also with other
medieval thinkers ranging from you know
Peter Abelard all the way into Thomas
and Bonaventure and some of the
Scholastic's before them and Skoda is an
ahkam and people along those lines and
then all of their successors going on in
Catholic and sometimes quite frankly
other Protestant institutions the
Lutheran's have their own form of
scholastic orthodoxy as well as did the
British so he says scholastic orthodoxy
has beautifully elaborated this
absolutist conviction in a doctrine
which it calls that of objective
evidence what does this mean there's
some things that we cannot doubt because
we just see that they're they're true he
says two is less than three or if all
men are moral I am mortal to these
illumine my intellect irresistible they
light up my my mind they have what
Descartes would call the natural light
shining in on them right
he says the certitude it brings involves
an aptitude in him odd extra condemns
care to missense him on the part of the
truth envisage and on the side of the
subject a who we act him in code Etzion
a which once the subject is mentally
received that leaves no possibility of
doubt behind and in the whole
transaction nothing operates but the
empty task of the object and the entity'
sips of the mind and he's delivered
deliberately using Latin there he says
we slouchy modern thinkers don't like
Latin but you know we've we've got our
own ways of doing things what do these
terms mean
it's basically saying that there is a
force that compels an assent on the part
of the mind that we're grasping the
thing itself the ante toss it's up and
we're doing so with the mind itself and
that the mind itself is able to reflect
and realize certitude in itself right
we are the creative in cognition a means
a rest in the thought of the thing of
being satisfied with the thing and so
the Scholastic's are saying this is the
basis for our true judgments that we
make and we can be completely certain
about these sorts of things so that's a
form of absolutism even modern stuff can
be absolutist though so he says our own
state of mind is very much like this
whenever we uncritically abandon
ourselves you believe in objective
evidence and I do of some things we feel
that we're certain we know and we know
that we do know there's something that
gives a click inside of us a bell that
strikes 12:00 when the hands of our
mental clock have swept the dial and
meet over the Meridian hour and here
James says something that we really
ought to take quite seriously says that
modern empiricists are often absolutist
of a different sort that they're only
what he calls empiricists upon
reflection that is that it requires the
active decision of the mind which means
the will is involved which means our
volitional nature our passional nature
is involved to keep us from falling back
into absolutism he also says that when
we're left to our own instincts
particularly when it's things that we
would definitely like to believe or
things we definitely not like to believe
that we behave as absolutists we Dogma
ties he says like infallible Pope's so
he uses as an example of this William
Clifford who says that it's sinful to be
Christians on insufficient evidence
insufficiency is not really what's going
on
here Clifford never really entertains
the possibility is alive hypothesis that
Christianity could have anything to it
there's no possibility of it having any
sufficient evidence so he rejects it out
of hand now one thing that that James
says outside of his section in the later
section about objectivity and certitude
he says that as empiricists if we give
up the doctrine of objective certitude
we don't give up the quest or the hope
of truth itself we still pin our faith
on its existence and we believe that
we're actually helping ourselves out
we're attaining he says a better
position by systematically continuing to
roll up experiences and think and then
he says here's the difference between
awesome peer assists and those
absolutists the strength of the system
for the absolutist lies in the
principles the origin the terminus
'equal the terminus the end from which
it begins so the starting points they
carry out things you might say with a
rather sophisticated but rigid way of
deductive a deductive argument ation or
logic
he says for us the strength is in the
outcome the upshot the terminus awed
quim where we arrive and so really what
James is talking about here is not just
empiricism this is also connected with
his conception of pragmatism we see what
the results are for our ability to
attain truth truth that we can use true
that we can live with and so James
doesn't think that we can ever embody
completely the empiricists type we're
always going to be lapsing into
absolutism here and there we can't avoid
becoming complete absolutist just as
much as we can avoid lapsing into a
skepticism that won't really allow us to
pursue truth and so empiricism becomes
you might say something like a
middle ground or middle way between
those two